David magno is in Perth Amboy New Jersey
where wind gusts up to 40 miles an hour
blowing the rain sideways that it's
never good David good morning to you
Gail Good Friday morning the rain
stopped right on cue
believe it or not can you believe it's
this mild on the first day of winter
hello from New York Harbor I got to tell
you it's mesmerizing when you look at
that radar and you see the rain coming
up from South Florida all the way pretty
much to Quebec Canada think about it
millions of people get ready to travel
for Christmas weather is the story of
the day no doubt we start down south
where the Sunshine State did not live up
to its name on Thursday heavy wind and
rain flooded roadways on what was the
worst travel day of the season lines of
drivers made their way through flooded
streets in Tampa tornadoes with winds of
up to 85 miles per hour spawn leaving a
trail of mangled homes across the state
it was scary it sounded like train like
a train going by it was really loud the
twisters uprooted trees knocked down
power lines nearly tore roofs off some
homes and damaged around 70 mobile homes
it was quite frightening it was scary it
was extremely quick the steady stream of
rain flooded parts of North Carolina
Maryland and Pennsylvania's the storm
moved north where wet weather delayed
travelers on the road and in the air it
took us four hours to drive to the
airport we wanted a direct plate and
it's all been good except the weather
you know if you live in the plain states
Oklahoma Nebraska Kansas the Dakotas or
anywhere around the Great Lakes heads up
you may want to pre-plan as to how
you're gonna get back after Christmas
because after Christmas they're supposed
to be some heavy snow so plan ahead and
get early for that behind I got to tell
you it's supposed to be 60 degrees is a
Big Apple of Manhattan today that's more
like where you and I are from down south
60 degrees this time of year I know I
was looking for a lighter coat to wear
this morning and leave it to the magic
of a David Berg no live shot that the
rain just stops for you